[Música]
en el día 42 de la invasión rusa en
ucrania moscú se repliega hacia la
región del donbass a las 10 del gobierno
de kiev las autoridades ucranianas
hicieron un llamado a la población a
evacuar esta región en la ciudad de
mariupol han muerto más de 5000 civiles
denunció su alcalde mientras que la otan
asegura que la guerra podría durar años
eeuu ya conocer una nueva ronda de
sanciones contra rusia a la casablanca
carga ahora contra las dos hijas del
presidente de la discuten y también
contra la familia de su canciller
sérguei lávrov además en más castigos
contra los bancos rusos y las
inversiones estadounidenses en ese país
pero el sector energético sigue al mar
a cuatro días de la primera vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales en francia
las encuestas siguen mostrando una
ventaja cada vez más estrecha entre el
presidente y candidato emanuel macrón y
la ultraderechista marine lepén apenas
tres puntos y medio de margen según ifo
el mandatario se apura por abordar el
escándalo de la consultora mckinsey
analizamos en esta emisión
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa en la pantalla de france 24
gracias por continuar con nosotros yo
soy juan rubiales día 42 de la invasión
de rusia en ucrania y eeuu asegura que
creen bien completó la retirada de sus
tropas de la región de kiev la capital y
de chernin hiv al norte según el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
moscú está enfocando ahora sus esfuerzos
en la región del donbass al este del
territorio y que pueden ver en rojo en
el mapa en su pantalla es en esas zonas
en donde hay presencia rusa mientras
tanto en la asediada ciudad de mariupol
más de 5000 civiles han muerto de
acuerdo con su alcalde y el comité
internacional de la cruz roja informó
que logró evacuar a 1000 personas de
esta urbe rumbo a sap orilla la vice
primera ministra ucraniana irina
bereziuk anunció que en total este
miércoles fueron evacuadas 4 mil 892
personas en esos corredores humanitaria
y ante esa concentración de las fuerzas
rusas en el donbass a las autoridades de
elegans una ciudad clave en esta región
instaron a la población a abandonar la
zona pero algunos habitantes se han
preparado para defender a sus hogares ya
sus familias
antes de ser destruido por las tropas
locales este puente era la única vía de
acceso al pueblo de bogor disk en el
este de ucrania
desde que moscú anunció su intención de
centrarse en lo que llamó la liberación
del donbass los residentes de la
tradicional región minera viven con el
temor constante de un asalto
norman mailer en este momento todo el
mundo está tenso todo el mundo está
esperando que ocurra algo pero en
realidad no saben lo que están esperando
a pocos kilómetros de la línea del
frente las tropas rusas se acercan a la
zona desde el norte se han establecido
bloqueos de carreteras alrededor de
estos pueblos como parte de los
esfuerzos para frenar el avance de los
tanques rusos las tropas ucranianas
dicen que están preparadas para un
ataque como ia crucis con la federación
fascista rusa llegó a nuestra sagrada
tierra ucraniana con una espada así que
todos morirán aquí por espadas y
sargentos en este pueblo este monasterio
cuyo techo resultó afectado por las
explosiones se encuentra entre los
edificios dañados por la guerra es vía
tories está a sólo 45 kilómetros al
norte de la estratégica ciudad de sliven
basque las fuerzas ucranianas están
desplegadas en la zona desde 2014
y en abril de 2014 esta zona fue
capturada por un grupo de fuerzas
especiales rusas
y por lo que podemos deducir quieren
honrar este aniversario ahora capturando
slogans gaming
ante el temor de que una ofensiva rusa
sea inminente miles de civiles intentan
huir hacia el oeste cada día
y a medida que rusia abandona la ciudad
de sucre venían a sus habitantes
regresan decenas de personas volvieron a
ser mi gif allí encontraron calles y
edificios destruidos
melissa chávez rincón tiene los detalles
lo que quedó fue un panorama de
destrucción más de la mitad de la
población huyó de chernin hiv una
localidad histórica al norte de ucrania
poco después del inicio de la guerra
pero con el retiro de las tropas rusas
decenas de habitantes regresaron al
esquí servo un aldeano de 98 años
recorre lo que un día fue su residencia
ahora en ruinas recuerda el día que
tuvieron que escapar
estaba acostado en la cama de mi casa
cuando algo golpeó la ventana era la
metralla los pedazos de vidrio volaron
por todas partes
los ciudadanos cuentan que los rusos los
sacaron de sus hogares a la fuerza les
quitaron sus documentos los celulares y
quemaron sus casas
ejército ruso ocupantes y agresores
destruyeron nuestra casa causaron daños
masivos a nuestro estado a cada familia
algunas personas perdieron a sus hijos
padres o abuelos cada familia tiene su
propio dolor forni si mejor
ahora las calles están llenas de restos
quemados de armas tanques y vehículos
militares rusos y ucranianos aunque han
vuelto a casa temen que las tropas rusas
regresen por lo que las autoridades han
habilitado corredores de ayuda y
evacuación la cifra de muertos en la
localidad continúa siendo indefinida
aunque el alcalde dijo que algunos días
enterraban hasta 100 personas chernin
hiv es la ciudad más grande del país de
la que los rusos se han retirado
lo avanzábamos en titulares eeuu anunció
una nueva oleada de sanciones que
apuntan directamente a los a las dos
hijas del presidente ruso vladimir putin
así como a dos de los mayores bancos
rusos unas sanciones a las que también
se ha unido reino unido y la europea son
una serie de castigos que llegan después
de que la comunidad internacional
conociera las atrocidades en la ciudad
de lucha en donde los cadáveres yacían
en las calles y se hallaron fuerzas
comunes
eeuu prometió aumentar el dolor sobre el
kremlin con un nuevo paquete de
sanciones así lo anunció el presidente
estadounidense joe biden a quien se le
quebró la voz al hablar de las
atrocidades cometidas por parte de las
fuerzas rusas contra la población civil
en boots a cerca de la capital ucraniana
primero eeuu va a imponer sanciones de
bloqueo total al sporting por lejos la
institución financiera más grande de
rusia y al alza bank su banco privado
más grande vamos a bloquear cualquier
cuenta y fondo que esos bancos tengan en
eeuu no van a poder tocar su dinero no
van a poder hacer ningún negocio aquí
segundo voy a firmar una orden ejecutiva
que va a prohibir cualquier inversión
estadounidense en rusia
las sanciones de washington apuntan a
las dos hijas del presidente ruso
vladimir putin como respuesta a lo que
consideran crímenes de guerra cometidos
en las cercanías de kiev reino unido por
su parte sumó la imposición de sanciones
a otros ocho oligarcas rusos y
culminarán las importaciones de petróleo
y carbón rusos para el próximo año
nuestras nuevas sanciones debilitarán
aún más la economía rusa poner fin a las
importaciones de energía rusa activos
helados del banco más grande de rusia y
seberbank prohibición total de nuevas
inversiones en el extranjero a rusia la
unión europea apunta hacia la presión en
el sector energético de moscú bruselas
del paso intentando culminar su
dependencia de los combustibles fósiles
rusos pero sin mencionar por ahora al
gas first en primer lugar impondremos la
prohibición de importar carbón de rusia
por valor de 4.000 millones de euros al
año y en worcester ya los expertos
citados por la casa blanca apuntan a que
esta nueva oleada de sanciones sumadas a
las anteriores supondrán que el pib de
rusia se contraiga hasta un 15% este año
vamos a francia porque a 4 días de la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales el mandatario y candidato
emanuel macrón sigue perdiendo ventaja
frente a la ultraderechista marine le
pen según las encuestas la aspirante de
agrupación nacional llega al 23,5 por
ciento de la intención de votos según un
estudio realizado por ifop macrón se
mantiene en una intención de voto del 27
por ciento es decir con un margen de
apenas 3,5 puntos porcentuales por su
parte candidato de extrema izquierda
jean-luc mélenchon llegaría el 17% para
analizar esos comicios nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de bogotá jhan majes
lleno académico y analista político
señor chen un gracias por estar con
nosotros estamos viviendo un repunte de
la extrema derecha en la recta final de
esta primera vuelta
buenas noches juanín gracias por la
invitación si hay un repunte de la
ultraderecha que era previsible que sí
que se veía venir digamos desde desde
todo el mandato de manuel marcan pero
que en las últimas semanas ha tenido
cierta dinámica digamos positiva para
este partido y entonces la ventaja que
tendría macro en la hipótesis de una
segunda vuelta contra marín depende la
otra derecha se está achicando entonces
ahí hay un riesgo de un cambio político
en francia se cree se quiere más que un
estado a pagando la factura del
escándalo de la consultora mckinsey
acusada de fraude fiscal y cuyos
servicios han sido contratados por el
actual gobierno francés
el mar contenía el apodo del presidente
de los ricos desde el inicio de su
mandato y yo creo que ese escándalo de
mckinsey es como la última el último
evento en una serie de eventos que
demuestra que marco ha gobernado digamos
pensando en algunas categorías de la
población y no necesariamente en para el
interés general en el escándalo de mack
15 se vio que más de 1000 millones de
euros fueron pagados a una empresa que
ya está investigada porque no paga
impuestos en francia y es una empresa
una consultora que había ayudado al
cambiar tu macro cuando era candidato
presidencial en la última elección
presidencial entonces ahí hay sospechas
fuertes de digamos de unas ventajas que
se le dieron a algunas empresas y
particularmente am a 15 y eso alimenta
nutre la
protesta digamos social y los proyectos
de la ultraderecha sobre otros
candidatos cree usted que antes de auge
del cual nos habla de la extrema derecha
ya tenemos que descartar cualquier
sorpresa del candidato de extrema
izquierda jean-luc mélenchon para de la
sorpresa y llegué a la segunda vuelta
bueno primero que todos los niños son de
extrema izquierda era del partido
socialista partido que ha gobernado
mucho en francia desde los años 80 y hoy
en día representa una alternativa de una
izquierda un poquito más radical que el
partido socialista pero tampoco de
ultraderecha y muchos más candidatos
hacia la izquierda de menos
está todavía lejos de the main event de
está lejos de clasificar sólo clasifican
dos para la segunda vuelta está lejos de
poder clasificar en este momento pero si
la dinámica ha sido positiva y hablar
estado muy activo en términos de eventos
de
apariciones en redes sociales en las
últimas semanas y yo creo que eso
todavía no se mide del todo en las
encuestas entonces puede que tenga una
votación un poquito más alta de lo que
se está previendo de ahí al llegar a ser
una vuelta hay muchas dudas todavía
mira el análisis de yamaha y chinoy de
cara a las elecciones presidenciales
siempre 74 hemos preparado una serie de
reportajes especiales sobre los temas
que marcan el escenario electoral hoy
hablamos de la economía doméstica que es
la principal preocupación de los
franceses una parte significativa del
electorado se queja de tener más gastos
que ingresos y nuestro periodista en
parece luís miguel cabrera nos acerca a
este tema decisivo de los comicios
el cólera en las calles de parís estos
franceses exigen un aumento de las
pensiones y los salarios insuficientes
para enfrentar el alza creciente de los
precios en especial de la alimentación y
el combustible una realidad que corroe
su calidad de vida y que las
estadísticas traducen en un incremento
de la inflación de 4.5 por ciento
interanual en marzo un récord en el
actual lustro la pérdida de poder
adquisitivo es una motivación electoral
fundamental para los franceses y los
candidatos a la presidencia lanzan sus
anzuelos entre sus promesas de campaña
la mayoría de los aspirantes de
izquierda propone aumentos de entre 120
y 230 euros al actual salario mínimo y
tanto la derecha como la izquierda echan
mano a una jugosa promesa la reducción
de impuestos de llegar a la presidencia
anne hidalgo marine lepén y valérie
pécresse disminuirían los que pesan
sobre la electricidad y el combustible y
ya anillado reduciría a aquellos sobre
los ingresos jean-luc mélenchon
eliminaría los concernientes a bienes de
primera necesidad
eriksen moore recortaría en más de 25%
las contribuciones a la seguridad social
para quienes tengan bajos ingresos
mientras emanuel disminuiría los
impuestos a la industria y la
agricultura y pondría fin a las
contribuciones de las empresas sobre el
valor agregado la revalorización del
poder adquisitivo pasa también por el
acceso a la vivienda que mantiene en
tensión a miles de familias y algunos
candidatos proponen limitar el aumento
de los alquileres varios aspirantes a la
presidencia macrón entre ellos proponen
aumentar la edad de jubilación a 65 años
otros mantenerla en 62 y algunos como
lepe mélenchon bajarla a 60 en el
quinquenio que termina el poder
adquisitivo de los hogares de clase
media y alta aumento en 7 por ciento
pero los hogares más pobres apenas
sobrepasó el 1 por ciento un asunto tan
sensible como la economía doméstica será
determinante en la decisión final de los
electores franceses en especial en el
actual contexto macroeconómico y
energético de gran incertidumbre por la
guerra en ucrania
en noticias del continente africano
miles de personas marcharon en varias
ciudades de ciudad en rechazo al golpe
militar del pasado mes de octubre y la
jornada termino cobrándose la vida de al
menos una persona desde jartúm la
capital hasta la región occidental de
darfur se vivieron estas marchas en las
que se pudo ver a la policía reprimir a
la multitud en medio del mes sagrado del
ramadán este miércoles precisamente se
cumplen tres años desde la caída del ex
presidente omar al-bashir la víctima
mortal que se registró hoy era un joven
de 19 años quien perdió la vida de un
disparo por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad denuncian fuentes médicas
desde el 25 de octubre el balance es de
94 fallecidos
y así terminamos esta emisión
informativa en france 24 pero quédense
porque la información continúa en
nuestra pantalla y también en france 24
punto com
[Música]